Hey everybody!
Hello!
Sexy dokey is back!
I figured, no way!
Come on!
Sexy!
I figured, what would be the most humiliating thing to lose
to?
And I figured I should bring back Sexy dokey.
but it also motivates you you know he's like a chance to
beat me up but so oh hey so I haven't I also haven't warmed
up today but it's okay it makes it more fair because you
guys haven't warmed up as well because you guys are at a
convention but yeah everybody I wish you everything but I
didn't warm up because I was too busy being sexy so Are you
guys ready to challenge me in the Apex 1v1 duel?
All right.
Because I also have not aimed in a while too.
As you guys know, I was too busy playing take.
And no aim, no brain.
Must be a Winston main.
So let's try.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, let's get this started.
Oh, I forgot.
I was charging my mouse.
Because I'm going to plug this back up.
Who is my first challenger?
Who is it?
Alright, where is he?
Where even is he here?
Oh, there he is!
Alright!
Now to see if the stack was a real dragon, put on the Watson
character.
Put it on.
Put it on the Watson character.
right now press L press the key you know I'm a real one all
right okay you gotta farm your armor real quick though I
don't even know how you can do that guess you gotta shoot me
until you get or shoot the bots until you get purple armor
yeah shoot those bots no that doesn't work anymore oh that
this is gonna be a real good challenge he doesn't know Armor
doesn't get, picking up armor doesn't give you the armor.
Yeah, it's all powered by damage now.
I didn't know either.
It just found out today.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Shoot the bots.
Yeah, shoot them.
Get your armor up.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right, little dragon.
But when you got this, Just keep shooting.
Just keep shooting.
Wait.
Snap.
Show me his speed.
I want to see his aim right now.
Show me his speed while he's shooting at bots.
I'm scouting out.
I need to scout out his aim.
All right.
Keep doing it.
It's not purple yet.
All right.
Load up.
Wingman R9.
Get that Kramer shit out of here.
And you're not one-shotting me with a Kramer.
We're doing a good old classic.
all right we're good four stacks of armor time to go to the
arena dome
he's like oh god don't worry i'm just as washed don't worry
today we're gonna find out if i'm washed or if i still got
uh but look at the sick ass tap shape though oh still got
that still got my movement whoa you see that guy who sees a
Whoa!
Watch this.
God, that's so cool.
That's so sexy.
All right, here we go.
The good old classic.
You go on that side.
I stay here.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
You're here.
I'm here.
We're going to do a little countdown.
And then we start from the bottom and then we go up top all
right we're gonna I'm gonna do I'm gonna shoot my gun we
start you ready all right oh wait I forgot attachment give
me a sec did it add a barrel stabilizer on the wingman what
oh look at that whoa mantle Joe all right give me a sec I
just realized that they added a new attachment Oh my gosh,
sorry, my voice changed, it broke for a second.
Yeah?
Oh shit, yeah, you couldn't hear game.
I've been muted that while I was at the beach, you know?
All right, here we go.
Now we have game audio.
All right, you ready for real this time?
Yeah, all right, here we go.
Three, two, one.
Press M and then you can, Yeah, that's right.
Get out of here.
All right, what is it?
Best of three or best of one?
I didn't even know the rules.
Best of three.
All right, you ready again?
All right.
This is me not having to warm up, by the way.
Oh, God, I'm so sexy.
Alright, I'm gonna start soon.
Bye!
Give me the next dragon into the gauntlet.
You lost a sexy jokie.
Whoa!
That's right.
You lost a me.
don't worry I'll give more and motivate the next dragon to
kill me who will defeat the evil hello hello dragon number
two are you ready you need to shoot a little bit to warm up
you need are you ready ready you're good all right all right
here we go three two one Oh, you're going on the side.
What a choice.
Oh, what a choice.
Oh, you know what?
Oh, not today.
Not today.
All right.
one more one
all right and three two one oh you're going for the side
again full choice
oh i'm lifting
i got a cheek open oh i'm lifting right now Never mind
headshot.
Oh, whoa, we got my armor's gone.
Get out of here.
Not today for you too.
Bring me the next dragon to the gauntlet.
You need some time.
You want to sell your ult?
You need a buff?
This gave me two.
Well, technically, like, you know, a couple of months.
All right.
Let me know when you're ready, bro.
Oh, yeah, you might have to adjust your sense if you
remember it.
I have to look up my own sense.
While we wait, look at these sick-ass kicks, guys.
Oh, still got it.
And I think we'd be kicking.
Boom!
Oh!
That's right.
Still got the jumps.
Oh, he's still adjusting his sense, guys.
Just plug in the controller.
We can even have a controller.
You should have been like, bring your own controller for a
real challenge.
Oh, you're ready?
All right, here we go.
we go all right in three two one I didn't shoot my gun what
are you doing get back over there someone didn't listen to
the rules get back over there shooting the gun the countdown
is just a courtesy all right three two one Oh,
I'm blifting my shots.
Come on.
I hear you.
That's right.
Get the feet up in the corner.
Like a good drag, man.
All right, back over there.
This is me.
This is me nurse, though.
Just saying, I was playing tape for two days.
I could not aim at all.
All right, here we go.
You ready?
Yeah.
I'm going to do, I haven't used my R9 in a while, so let's
use that.
What?
The disadvantage.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Still got it.
Send in the next challenge.
This is so quick.
You might need to call in five, ten more dragons.
in here.
It's going so fast for me.
Should I kill them slower, guys?
Alright.
Yeah, if you need to adjust your sense or anything, you
good.
You good there?
No need to adjust your sense.
He's adjusting.
Let me know when he's ready.
Is he ready?
Yep, there you go.
All right, let's go, all right.
Three, two, one.
Now I have a session today.
Oh, oh, okay, never mind.
I saw him hit one shot now, so I can press.
Oh!
He just died too.
He didn't want to get beat up.
All right, are you ready?
Someone, turn around.
all right here we go
oh we both oh he's hitting shot oh it's too bad not enough
though oh yeah come
on where's your best triangle to take me down sexy donkey
will be here forever the first triangle that defeats sexy
Doki will get the honor of picking the next Doki on the
screen.
Whoa, that could be any Doki from the Dokiverse, but no Doki
defeats me, it's sexy Doki till the end of the paddle.
No!
I know, it's just too much sexiness in the world.
It's just so overbearing, I know.
guys let me know when you're ready dragon go back to that
side this is my side this is the winning side the winner
side oh he's practicing his move whoa where is he going
where is he going Did he forfeit the challenge?
Oh my god, I win!
Yay!
What is he trying to move?
This guy's not the godly area.
Oh, he's getting, what is he getting?
I can't see, I'm so far away.
Oh, is he getting his skull?
Oops!
What is he doing?
Oh, he's getting attacked.
Wait, did none of you guys have attachments on your guns?
Oh my god!
He has her hot wrist ripped to the test subjects.
That attachment.
That's awkward.
Disappointation.
Oh my god, I was beating up like kids.
I wouldn't have it any other way.
You know, you could have got your stuff here in the supply
box.
There was a supply box right here.
I'm enjoying the moment.
Just having a nice leisurely stroll around the practice
range.
That, oh, this might be a natural, challenging.
How old are you, sir?
I don't need it.
And
he doesn't need it.
Oh, shit.
That's hardcore, bro.
All right.
You ready?
Sure.
And that guy would be anyway.
Oh!
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, he doesn't need it.
Really didn't need it.
Whoa.
All right, cool.
Okay.
Let me not fuck around anymore.
Alright.
You ready?
Okay.
You might actually do this.
Sexy Tokyo has been defeated.
Now I'm not happy.
next try everyone's gonna get something that's for sure I
guess I gotta lock in now all right the winner of that wonky
one what doky would you like on the screen what doky did he
want in what doky did he say I can't hear that won't keep it
Is that dragon on the other side ready?
Give me a second hydrate.
All right, I'm locking in now.
Not letting that happen again.
I was playing with my food too much.
All right, here we go.
You ready?
You're gonna start there?
All right.
That's right, no longer playing with my food anymore.
We're gonna speed run this.
Now I'm mad.
Sexy Doki is mad now.
Oh, we're standing.
Alright, alright.
Sure.
I'm ready.
Resistance!
Oh my god, what's your move?
Bro.
What is that?
guy's movement.
Your movement was so weird.
I couldn't fucking figure that shit out.
Alright, let me know how you're ready.
I'm serious sexy jokie now.
Alright.
Oh shit, that was gonna be a jiggle beef.
What the fuck was that movement?
Oh shit!
Yo, geez, your movement was so weird.
I didn't know how to comprehend it.
That was a good try, that was a good try.
You walked in one direction, it didn't like register in my
head.
I'm too used to stretching.
all right let me know whenever you're ready dragon all right
here we go you know what the
good old trusty on oh yeah that was your last one wait that
wasn't your last one we're speed running I'm all glaring
together all these dragons so many of them.
So many dead goons.
Alright, you ready?
Which side am I going to come up?
Ooh, it could be the left, it could be the right, it could
be top.
Alright, you're not as good as that other dragon.
So close.
the Watson.
I'm so used to what we wanting with Ray.
The Watson, the hitbox is so weird.
The salt and the upgrade.
I need it.
You want?
Can I take the dope?
All right.
Let me know if you're ready.
All right, here we go.
I'm done with this.
Oh,
he's confused.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, where am I?
There's a high to see there.
Playing with your head.
All right, go back there.
Go back to the beginning, bro.
All right.
Thank
you, guys.
I think I'm just super washed out.
on the wingman.
I'm missing the easiest shots of my life.
To be fair, it's like no, it's been so long since I've used
a fucking pistol.
All right, next dragon.
Get back to your station.
Get over there.
It's like, oh, I'll take you there faster.
I'll fist you over.
Hey.
Good.
I don't know, guys.
What does that mean?
So when you spin, it's just punching, right?
Sure.
All right, are you ready?
Is that going ready?
Yeah.
All right.
Got you by surprise.
That's right.
I ain't playing no more.
No drag movement is gonna get me playing with my food
anymore.
I'm sorry.
Alright, you ready?
Oh shit, never mind, maybe I am playing with my food.
What the fuck was that in?
That's right, I'm the better tracker.
Maybe I was playing with my food and we don't count the
first two shots there.
Oh, oh, starting to get warmed up now.
Not with the wingman though.
The wingman was a little, still like I'm playing like a
bronze right now.
Maybe I should have warmed up a little with it.
I'm like, don't even know how people move anywhere.
I'm like, where's my body?
I'm thinking in third person.
I see my own skin.
My beautiful skin.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, I think you should do my strap, bro.
To do my strap, you should be able to aim.
There you go.
One more, one more, yay!
Oh, I'm waiting.
Oh, I hear his footsteps.
Oh, he's scared.
He's scared, he's afraid.
I know what to do there.
I'm
faster so I can beat up more of you.
I remember my motivation is that one dragon, never again.
That's right, it's a cycle and I'm never breaking that
cycle.
You ready for the rest of us?
I can't see how it's next.
You ready, little guy?
All right,
well, congratulations on winning the gotcha.
Here, I'll be a little nicer.
Oh, I shouldn't be nicer.
I'm so still for you.
You do know how to...
Oh, that's...
You gave me a false sense of security there.
trying to bait me there.
What part of that was nice, right?
All right.
See, that's why you should never be nice.
Look at him.
He baited me.
Oh, God, I would have hit this old past joke.
He would have hit those.
What happened the past cooler joke.
Yeah, where?
Where's the enemy?
There she is.
Goodbye.
Thanks for coming to you.
All right, next struggles!
Keep them coming!
I hung it for more blood.
Next struggle.
Yeah?
Probably not doing this.
Same to beat you.
Oh, yeah, that's supposed to be my hardest challenger.
All right.
I'll make sure I don't go easy on him.
Oh, yeah.
I just love him.
Also, give me that dragon's name that beat me.
He's living referee in my head right now.
I need to know his name.
Come back to the next Oshi, I'll make sure to practice this
time.
I'll be back stronger.
All right.
All right, ready?
Anything would be energizing.
Oh my God.
Oh my god, it really is
too.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it has been a while, hasn't it?
All right, you ready?
No good?
Good show, good show.
A real challenge there.
The fisting challenge.
All right, make sure you got your sense and everything.
Don't worry, don't worry, I haven't warmed up.
I haven't been playing tape for the last few days.
It's almost the same.
You two years, me two days.
All right.
Oh, he's gonna be like, where am I?
Where am I?
Oh, where am I?
I couldn't be here.
Whoa, so look at him now.
Whoa,
goodbye.
Oh, you got some shots in.
All right, here we go, here we go.
Oh, he's saying hi, girl.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Let's try.
She pushing it was not it for you.
I don't think she missed my cut.
Next dragon.
It's almost the same thing.
60 frames, 200.
Like, it's almost there.
You can sort of see your player model.
As long as you shoot the blob, they die, you know?
Like, unless you're baiting me like that, how they're going?
I don't trust it now.
You could be baiting me.
All right, ready?
Is that goo ready?
All right.
Oh, he went.
Oh, wait.
Maybe he does only play on this match.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe you weren't fitting me.
I don't know.
Maybe you're playing the lawn game.
And then you're going to lock in on the last match.
I don't trust none of you guys anymore.
All right, here we go.
That's funny, yes.
Hi, Doki.
All right, next dragon.
I'm Coyote, and it's a pleasure to kill or be killed by you.
Oh, all right.
Let's go.
Hey, Coyote.
All right, before we begin, what's your rank in Apex?
I haven't played Apex in, like, four years.
Alright, that's all I need, that's all I need.
Alright, let me know when we're ready.
I'm ready.
Alright.
Oh, where did you go?
Yeah, I realized.
Maybe don't wear windbag for me.
Go back to what I've built, to this true bread and butter.
All right, you need more time, need more time to remember
mechanics from four years ago?
Is that coyote from four years ago?
Oh, I'm with it.
See, this is why I don't bring up a wingman.
I don't bring it out, don't worry.
because they're like flat level or some shit.
So in a way, if you die to my wingman, you die to a plath.
And sexy yokey, I don't know what's worse.
Dying to sexy yokey or dying to a plath.
All right, let me know whenever you're ready.
Yep.
Also, what's your rank?
I should start asking that.
What is your rank, sir?
What?
Okay.
Unless that's a bait, I don't know.
People lying on the internet?
Nah, I can't beat it.
Don't hear his words.
Wait a minute, he wasn't lying.
Why?
See what you didn't lie?
You should have.
Goodbye.
diffuse my kindness all right let me know whenever you're
ready oh oh he wants to start it all right you know I'm just
gonna stab him in the wing bed it's my a la ink practice I'm
doing ink laps right now give me a sec
Goodbye, everyone.
Goodbye.
Hello.
Last one.
Oh my god, what's your name?
Global Elite Master.
Wrong game, but all right.
The last one.
Last one, I guess we gotta maybe give them a show then,
don't we?
Wrong side, by the way.
We should, inside, yeah, it's not us too, bro.
Okay.
Whoa, last one.
We gotta give them a show.
All right.
You know what, how about you start the match?
You shoot your gun and start it.
Whoa!
All right, because that is the last game or we get the
ticket to the final round.
Give me your arm, man.
Shoot the gun whenever you're ready.
He shot the gun.
It's fair.
He shot it.
He shot the gun and then AFK.
All is fair.
He said, go.
I was like, okay.
You think I will give him a freebie just because he's AFK?
It's war out there.
Oh, okay, let's go.
All right, almost undefeated.
What was his name?
Staff, give me his name, Dawson, for me.
He will live right free in my head.
The one dragon that got me my surprise.
Get over here.
The issue is I did not warm up on the wingmen, but I still
will taste a chat room that's challenged.
What is your name?
All right, I'll let you start it too.
Best of five?
That's a lot of games, guys.
That's all right, I'll take it.
Yeah, I'm ready.
You started.
All right.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, he wants to do our 9-2.
The wrong sense the entire time.
Give me a sec.
I just realized I might have been playing the wrong sense.
Okay, no.
All right.
It's fine.
We got this.
Fuck it.
Let's do this with wrong sense time.
I'm ready.
Oh, you don't want to play.
up I don't want to push up I we're very patient he knows my
weakness is a lot of range right now look at him he's taking
fucking so much distance from me he He knows.
He's rededding.
He...
Close
to me!
I don't lane!
No!
No, sweetie!
Yeah, plug in there.
Maybe you need an aim assist, bro.
I don't need aim assist to win against you.
I'm not against you!
I'm not.
All right.
Without
an upgrade, I'm at a disadvantage.
Oh, it's getting close now.
You got the headache.
Stupid ass wingman, I should delete this gun.
This gun is fucking stupid as hell.
Two
coffee there.
Next one wins.
I need to stop being two coffee there.
Give me those three free shots.
I need to be patient, but I can't be patient.
My weakness.
You know what,
I'll give you a fair fight with them.
Wingman, good game, good game, man.
I knew I should have trusted my goal the other night.
Let it be known, high flicks lives in
your...
Till next year, till next year, I'll make sure to practice,
I'll make sure to warm up before it lives.
The one goon that got
her.
Photo time.
Hope you all framed this through photo.
She's beautiful!
Yeah!
Some might say I'm sexy.
We're sexy!
Wait, I can make it bigger.
Everybody